was there ever a time that you had a
crisis of Faith where you questioned
your belief in God sure and I I would
let's call it a crisis of Faith than an
ongoing question of Faith which I think
is I hope most religious people
and the the word Israel right in in
Hebrew Israel means to struggle with God
that's that's the that's literally what
the word means and so the idea of
struggling with God right we're if
you're Jewish or banega Israel right the
the idea of struggling with God I think
is endemic to The Human Condition if you
understand what God's doing then I think
you're wrong
and if you think that that question
doesn't matter then I think you're also
wrong I think that God is a very
necessary hypothesis it's a struggle the
struggle with God is life that is the
process of life that's right because
you're never going to get to that answer
otherwise your God you aren't so why
does God allow cruelty and suffering in
the world one of the tough questions so
we're going deep here uh there there's
two types of Cruelty and suffering so if
we're talking about human cruelty and
suffering because God does not intervene
to prevent people from exercising their
free will because to do so would be to
deprive human beings of the choice that
makes them human
and this is the center of the Garden of
Eden basically is that God could make
you an angel in which case you wouldn't
have the choice to do the wrong thing
but so long as we are going to allow for
cause and effect in a universe shaped by
your choice cruelty and evil are going
to exist and then there's the question
of just the natural cruelty and
vicissitudes of life
and the answer there is I think that God
obscures himself I think that if God
were to appear in all of his glory to
people on a regular basis I think they
would make
faith and you wouldn't need it there'd
be no such thing as faith right it would
just be reality right nobody has to
prove to you that the sun rises every
day
um but if if God is to allow us the
choice to believe in him which is the
ultimate Choice from a religious point
of view then he's going to have to
obscure himself behind tragedy and
horror and and all those other things I
mean this is a fairly well-known
kabbalistic concept called Tsum Tsum in
in Judaism which is the idea that when
God created the universe he sort of
withdrew in order to make space for all
of these things to happen so God doesn't
have an instrumental perspective on
Liberty uh
in in a chief sense he he does because
the the best use of Liberty is going to
be belief in him and you can misuse your
Liberty right help
there will be consequences if you
believe in an afterlife or if you
believe in sort of a generalized better
version of Life led by faith uh then
Liberty does have a purpose but he also
believes that you have to give people
from a cosmic perspective the Liberty to
do wrong without threatening all the
institutions of society I mean that's
that's why it does say in the Bible that
if man sheds Blood by man shall his
blood be shed right there are
punishments that are that are
in biblical thought for doing things
that are wrong so for a human being who
lacks the faith in God so if you're an
atheist can you still be a good person
of course 100 and there are a lot of
religious people who are crappy people
how do we understand that tension well
from a religious perspective what you
would say is that it is perfectly
plausible to live
in accordance with a set of rules that
don't damage other people without
believing in God you just might be
understanding the reason for doing that
wrong is what a religious person would
say
um there's the conversation again that I
had with Sam basically is you and I
agree I said this to Sam you and I grew
on nearly everything when it comes to
morality like we probably disagree on 15
to 20 of things the other 80 is because
you grew up in a judeo-christian society
and so do I and we grew up 10 miles from
each other you know around the turn of
the Millennium so there's that
um so you can perfectly well be an
atheist living a good moral decent life
because you can live a good moral decent
life with regard to other people without
believing in God I don't think he built
a society on that because I think that
you know that relies on these sort of
goodness of mankind natural goodness of
mankind I don't believe in the natural
goodness of mankind you don't no I
believe in I believe that man has
created both sinful and with the
capacity for sin in the capacity for
good but if you let them be on their own
isn't doesn't it without social
institutions to shape them I think that
that's very likely to go poorly oh
interesting well we came to something we
disagree on but that may be uh that
might reflect itself in our approach to
Twitter as well I think if humans are
left on their own
uh they they attend towards good
they definitely have the capacity for
good and evil but I one left on their
own there
um I I tend to believe they're good
I think they might be good with limits
what I mean by that is that what the
evidence I think tends to show is that
human beings are quite tribal so what
you'll end up with is people who are
good with their immediate family and
maybe their immediate neighbors and then
when they're threatened by an outside
tribe then they kill everyone
which is sort of the history of
civilization in the pre-civilizational
era which was a very violent time
pre-civilization later was quite violent